right so what's cool at school well when
you're looking for a friendly big game
challenge why go to the leaders of the
cities and the states where the teams
are from when you can go straight to
the principal's office well yeah the
rams are playing the bengals sunday but
did you know those same two teams are
challenging each other right here in las
vegas from the clark county school
district it's the rams of rancho taking
on the bengals of bonanza to see what
each will do if the other team wins we
start with principal darlene delgado and
her team from rancho high school the
rams are going to win so we're really
full-blown ready to go we're going to
win
so you're looking forward to bonanza
people wearing rancho jerseys absolutely
we even have the jerseys ready for them
to wear
sorrancho is one of the oldest high
schools here in clark county we opened
in 1954.
oh my gosh so the bengals are the young
kids they opened in 1976. they better
respect their elders this team does not
look good in tiger stripes so get ready
for the green there it is
principal george anis and his team from
bonanza high school they came roaring
right out of the gate you guys are fired
up for the super bowl yeah we can't wait
we're gonna crush the rams just in case
if by some chance the rams should happen
to win would you agree to put on a
rancho jersey for a day oh my goodness
so i don't know stop
no
oh
okay because i don't have to worry about
it because the bengals are gonna win
anyway so
[Applause]
a little shade there that sounds like a
double throw down to me well i guess
we're just gonna have to wait until
monday to find out which principal is
going to be wearing the other school's
jersey so much fun hanging out with the
admin teams from both rancho and bonanza
now if you know something that's cool at
school let us know cool at school is
under the community tab at eight
newsnow.com or just send us an email
cool it's cool eightnewsnow.com so much
fun they were so into it but each one is
ready for the other school to wear their
jerseys oh well i don't know
it didn't seem like the bengals
principal there is so ready to wear the
other